مرحباً بالجميع، اسمي غادي موزس، جئت إلى آنا في الأسر
لشهر أكتوبر
في ظروف ليست اختيارية
شخصيا أريد أن أعطي
الى اصدقائي
الى أنصاري
التي يجب أن تزيد الضغط ل
نرجو أن تفهم الحكومة ما نريد ونريده
سنبذل قصارى جهدنا قريبًا للعودة قريبًا
منزل صديقنا عائلتنا إلى منزلنا الذي كان هادئًا
وهادئ أمام نتنياهو جلينز ​​غانز
ورغبة قلبي انتبهوا لهذا الوضع الذي نحن فيه
يمكن أن يموت في أي لحظة هو وضع لا يطاق
فرصة معقولة أننا سوف نقتل مرة أخرى
الليلة لأنه ليس هناك ما يضمن أن جيشنا
عدم قصفنا أيضًا في خطر
تسقط علينا قنبلتنا تشعرك بأنك لست كذلك
هل تريد أن تعيدنا إلى المنزل أحياء؟
لجعل الجثث تخفض السعر فليس هكذا
أنت على استعداد لتلقي قسائم الخصم
سأجمع ابن الحصاد
47 أنا الآن في غزة أسير الغيد
الوضع صعب للغاية بالنسبة لنا هنا، فنحن في خطر على حياتنا بسبب التفجيرات
إسرائيل، نختتم حياتنا هنا
أفتقد حقا المنزل فقط أريد العودة
إسرائيل يطلبها رئيس وزراء إسرائيل وكل شيء
صناع القرار يفعلون كل ما يتطلبه الأمر
أطفئ النار وقم بصفقة تبادل أسبوعية
وبعد ذلك يمكننا العودة إلى ديارنا، فنحن لا نريد أن نكون في غزة
حياتنا هنا الآن خطيرة للغاية
ونريدهم أن يفعلوا كل ما يتطلبه الأمر
يعيدنا
البيت